pick up the point about small and large
population countries in fact
the greatest part of my focus this year
is on the decarbonization of the Chinese
economy I'll be spending about six weeks
in total in China probably not in the
next couple of weeks has been a little a
little little delay in the launch of our
next thing and what we are trying to do
there is to persuade China that it could
be a zero carbon economy by 2050. uh Xi
Jinping has a phrase China 2050 a fully
developed Rich economy and we have
recently produced a report called China
2050 a fully developed Rich zero carbon
economy now is China a capitalist or a
socialist country economy it's called
locally a economy of socialism with
Chinese characteristics
um
some people think it would be better be
called a capitalist economy with Chinese
characteristics it's a funny mix but it
has a very Dynamic private sector the
solar PV planners the uh the uh the
batteries the EVS are all being
developed by amazingly uh Dynamic uh
Chinese entrepreneurs overlapping with a
state sector many of which are those
state-owned companies almost act as if
they were private companies in the terms
of the way they uh look after the
managers of those so it's it's a
complicated thing to understand but it
is certainly a form of market economy
with many of the aspects of capitalism
to it still building coal-fired and I
have to say if I turned up well let me
come back to that if I turned up there
and said okay guys what you have to do
is to reject capitalism
we'd get nowhere right what happens in
China is fundamental their emissions are
now 10 gigatons of CO2 12 gigatons
including the other greenhouse gases
ours are uh 450 and falling even on a
per capita basis they are going above UK
and European levels and to win the
argument in China
there is only one way to do it which is
to convince them that it is
technologically possible for them to be
a proud Rich developed society in which
Chinese people enjoy the opportunities
the economic opportunities that we enjoy
that it's technologically possible to do
that and be a zero carbon economy that's
that's how you have to win it and in
order to deliver it you also have to use
powerful market economy techniques
involving entrepreneurs competing within
one another to drive down the cost of
batteries to drive down the cost of
electrolysis equipment to drive down the
cost of solar PV so I think when you
look at that large population country
whereas I say that is where most of my
focus is this year I would say the idea
that we have to approach this issue by
suggesting the rejection of capitalism
is just completely the wrong way I'm
going to pause you there wants to come
in yeah on the question of subsidies so
in 2009 the biggest richest countries in
the world the G7 came together and
agreed to phase out fossil fuel
subsidies 2009 okay so that's why I'm
convinced that coming together and
trying to get these agreements which
then are negated is impossible in this
system without something else happening
and that something else happening is
first of all I think my opponents need
to accept the failures of the system and
that's why I'm here to convince you but
also to convince them to have a little
bit of a wake-up moment a little bit of
atonement a little bit of a yes we
failed because we did not recognize the
magnitude of the political weight and
the magnitude of the problems cannot be
fixed with techno managerial Solutions
the second point I want to make is about
populations so many of the countries
that you suggested many of the
continents that you suggested have
extremely low per capita emissions it's
not the size of the populations that
matters it's their consumption whether
they're doing it within their own
countries or offshoring it actually
elsewhere so China's emissions are
mainly coming from us and consumption by
us a lot of that is you can't you can't
say something which is just not true
let me finish let me finish well that's
10 is still alive but it's not it's not
most it's not it's not all but but it's
the richest people in the in this
country that are responsible for the
bulk of the UK's emissions so the you
know the bottom 75 percent you know the
remember the Pyramid of extraction they
don't fly they don't have cars they
don't have second homes they don't have
the kind of luxury Lifestyles so I think
we need to not keep looking at whether
it's population that's the driver and I
think Tony's also you know very fixated
on population as the driver of you know
destruction is actually this extractive
system which accumulates for the benefit
of I want to get there's a whole Cube